desafiando el nuevo plan de control
migratorio de los Estados Unidos miles
de venezolanos partieron en la madrugada
de este viernes desde Tapachula la
ciudad fronteriza de México con
Guatemala esta nueva caravana de
migrantes venezolanos le está pidiendo
al gobierno de Estados Unidos una
prórroga de 15 días calendario para que
no sean afectados por la medida tomada
este miércoles por el secretario de
seguridad Alejandro mayorcas de
deportarlos a cambio Estados Unidos está
ofreciendo 24.000 visas humanitarias a
venezolanos directamente con ciertas
restricciones como ingresar por aire y
también tener familiares en territorio
estadounidense Y es que hasta la fecha
de Estados Unidos había permitido la
permanencia de todos aquellos
venezolanos que tras un largo periplo
por Centroamérica y México habían
logrado cruzar ilegalmente hacia Estados
Unidos pero ahora esa permanencia será
negada y primeramente serán deportados
hacia México luego hacia Venezuela el
país natal sobre porque en el año fiscal
2022 se ha registrado un aumento de
cerca del 300% de flujo migratorio con
respecto al 2021 protagonizado por
venezolanos venezolanos que aún huyen de
su país natal por la crisis económica
que además están aprovechando la
reapertura de fronteras tras dos años de
cierre por la pandemia de Kobe 19 y
quienes además están saliendo
masivamente de Colombia el país que los
acogió en masa pero que ahora temen que
se convierta en una nueva Venezuela tras
la llegada al poder del presidente de
izquierda Gustavo Petro